in a world that can seem overwhelming
and stressful it's good to know someone
has you covered bear hug
weighted blankets by deep calming
pressure two key parts of your body to
reduce anxiety while you sleep
but what about those moments of stress
you experience throughout the day well
now you can have that same soothing
feeling wherever you need with bear hug
weighted wearables our fashions are made
from the same material as our blankets
and are available in a multitude of
weights light massage staring at a fish
tank and tested negative for herpes
first time trying arrows and pull the
bottom with fashions to help you stay
calm through every stressful occasion
nerve-wracking job interview
uncomfortable hospital messengers
walking down the aisle on your big day
and getting in the mood for your big
night bear hug weighted wearables now
you can stop stressing and start living
in style now available at Target
Nordstrom Ross Dress for Less Men's
Wearhouse bretherton one Gymboree and
most all rental locations bear hug
weighted wearables our subsidiary of
Paraguay blankets family-owned business
since 1982 the business was started by
Gerald bear-hug a clinical psychologist
specializing in the treatment of
post-traumatic stress disorder in
military dogs bear hug weighted
wearables we've got you covered
[Applause]